I guess, is that what happened?
There's a lot that happened.
I mean, you want to get into the
is this therapy?
You want me to really go go into it?
Welcome back, everyone is Charlie.
There's been a little bit of Rick
and Morty news recently.
Adult Swim and Rick and Morty just fired
Justin Roiland,
one of the creators of the show,
after it was revealed
that he'd been arrested a few years ago
for some really heinous stuff
that opened a bunch of floodgates
in a bunch of disturbing
things that he'd been doing in his past
also leaked out.
Oh, my God, Rick, we're at real trouble
today.
You know, so in the wake of that,
a lot of the shows that he's working on
or created
or involved in making either fired him
or he's resigned of his own accord.
Rick and Morty
and Adult Swim in particular
have issued a formal statement
about how they plan
to deal with this really unfortunate,
really horrifying turn of events.
Their formal statement just read Adult
Swim has ended its association
with Justin Roiland,
and that was basically it.
They posted similar messages to the Adult
Swim and Rick and Morty social accounts,
but also added this extra bit
about the future of Rick and Morty.
The show saying
Rick and Morty will continue.
The talented and dedicated crew are hard
at work on season seven and the Hollywood
Reporter confirmed
with Adult Swim that their plan
was to recast the roles of Rick and Morty.
Like everybody, the Justin Roiland
voiced continue making the show
until at least season ten, with Dan Harmon
just being the sole creator
working on the show,
Justin Roiland would have
no more association with making the show.
So whatever extra stuff
they found during their independent
investigation
of all the stuff that happened
when they charges came to light
was bad enough
that they fired him on the spot
rather than wait for the trial
to actually happen.
The show is a cash cow for Adult Swim,
so they could be trying to save face
and just fire him earlier
just because being associated with him
is so toxic to the show.
They don't want to hurt the profits
to the show because he hasn't been
officially convicted of the charges yet.
He has been accused of them.
He was arrested for them
a couple of years ago.
But when this was all announced,
a lot of people wondered
if it was going to kill the show because
Justin Roiland essentially is the show.
He voices
so many of the important characters,
the main characters,
and he does it on a couple
of different shows.
Rick and Morty is just one of them.
He also does the same thing on solar
opposites, voicing a bunch of characters.
He also has a video game
studio called Squatch Games, named
after his character
Squishy from Rick and Morty.
They just released a new game
high on life,
so their armies of just regular people
working on the shows in various capacities
in the games that he makes
that depend on those for their living.
Obviously,
they're hoping that him going down
is going to take that stuff down with him.
Earlier today, Squatch games separately
also confirmed that Justin Roiland
had recently quit
the studio of his own accord,
meaning that he wasn't fired by them,
but he owned the studio effectively.
Like he started it with his own money.
So there really wasn't like,
a board of directors
that could get together and fire him
if they wanted to.
But they're not associated with Adult Swim
that it's a completely separate venture
that he started on his own.
Just to explain
what's going on, if you're confused about
why he's in the middle
of this giant scandal or what it was
he did that he was accused of,
it's actually a series of things he did
going back years in a few separate events,
coming to a head at the same time,
like the perfect storm of someone's
terrible behaviors, coming back to
bite them in the ass all at the same time.
The main thing that sent all this off
was him going to court.
Recently, news outlets learned, one,
that he was in court for something
and that that was really bad.
And then once they did some digging,
find out what the charges were.
They found out that a couple of years
ago, in 2020, he was arrested
for the false imprisonment
and battery of his former girlfriend.
She was the person that filed the charges
that was named in the lawsuit
in the lawsuit,
which is going to actual trial
now like it took a couple of years for it
to actually go to trial.
And that's why we're finding out about it.
Wrongful imprisonment is basically defined
as holding someone against their will,
like trapping them in
a house is in the case was Justin Roiland
he trapped his former girlfriend
in their house
either under the threat of a lie
or actual physical violence.
The battery charge
is this them getting into
an actual physical fight with someone?
It sounds like what happened is it just
Roland tried to force his girlfriend
to stay inside their home for some reason
or would not let her leave
under threat of force or just lie to her
and she was able to call the police
to get out and then they got into a fight.
That's all we've really learned
about the event from the court documents.
We'll probably find out
more during the actual trial
when it happens
later this year in October.
Either way, it is not good.
Like there is no version of that scenario
where he comes out looking good.
What had happened
the last couple of years,
though,
is that he just tried to keep it quiet.
So we're just finding out about now
because it went to actual trial
like news outlets found out about it
from the actual court documents
that had to be filed.
The other even more disturbing thing
that was revealed
is that separately text of his
that he sent to underage girls years ago
leaked out in
it turns out as part of a pattern
of behavior that he's had in the past,
you may have seen
some of the texts in your feeds.
I can't put them in the video
because they're that crazy.
Like YouTube would be in the video.
That's how hardcore disgusting
they are during them.
It actually sounds like he's trying
to speak as the actual Morty character.
Like is if he were Morty in real life
speaking to these younger girls,
that by itself
would probably be enough to get him fired
from all the shows that he's working on.
There's been a lot of statements recently
from people in the animation industry
saying that he's been doing things
like this,
like his behavior
has been this bad for years,
and it's been kind of an open secret
in Hollywood up to this point.
And they've just been able to keep it
quiet up to this point.
He hasn't addressed the charges
or anything that's happened
the last couple of weeks
since the news came to light.
His lawyer has only said the media
coverage of the case has been inaccurate.
To be clear, not only is just an innocent,
but we also have every expectation
that this matter is on course
to be dismissed.
Once the district attorney's office
has completed
its methodical review of the evidence.
So they seem pretty confident that he's
going to get off on all of these charges
and won't serve any actual jail time,
because if he is convicted,
he will serve some hard jail time.
So we still don't know how much truth
there is in any of these statements.
But either way,
it just sounds like a pattern
of really terrible behavior,
really toxic behavior.
So the only path forward for all the stuff
he's working on, all the different shows
the games, is to part ways with him.
Even if he's exonerated,
that doesn't mean he's
going to go back and start working
for all these people again.
Those of you asking
if this is going to kill the shows
that he's working
on, like will this kill Rick and Morty?
Because he's basically
most of the characters on his own?
There have been lots of examples
in the past of shows
recasting high profile actors,
particularly animated shows.
I am sure Dan Harmon in Adult Swim
are combing Tik-Tok right now
looking for Rick and Morty impersonators
that can do Justin's voice.
Part of the joke of Rick and Morty
and his other shows
is that most of his voices
sound very similar.
He even jokes about it himself.
He can only do a couple of voices.
This isn't really a joking matter,
but if Adult Swim wanted to pull
another stunt like April Fool's Day
episode, they should replace him with
Michael Cusack, a Bush World adventures
and just never address it.
40 300 Rick in the car.
Morty, get in the car.
Rick goes to sleep.
Oh, what's going
on? Rick? What's happening?
We're going on an adventure. Morty.
Classic. Rick Morty Bush lead adventure.
We're going to go for a drive.
If you don't remember, Bush World
Adventures was a short episode
that they aired on Adult Swim on April
1st, 2018.
One year
after the original April Fool's Day prank.
Personally, I think that Rick and Morty
as a show will be fine.
Dan Harmon has always been
the actual real writer
in the room who turned Justin Roiland
initial bit into an actual show.
Like he made it into an actual show.
When you hear them
talk about the actual process
of making the show like them, writing
episodes, creating the show,
a lot of it is Dan Harmon
in the other writers,
making it like a regular show
like you would expect,
and a lot of Justin Roiland
coming up with random bits on the fly
that they'd write into episodes.
Really good example is the Nintendo rant
from season two.
You guys, we got to hurry.
I just got back from Walmart.
They're selling Nintendo 3DS systems
for one 4999 on sale.
Plus every time you buy one
you get a $50 gift card.
Nintendo, give me free stuff. Okay. Yes.
That scene was basically word for word,
something that Justin Roiland did in
real life one day running into the writers
room yelling about how they had
to buy a bunch of Nintendo's to corner
the market unironically, mind you.
So as long as Rick and Morty
can find a sound alike impersonator,
that's good enough.
There is functionally
no change in how the show gets made
or the way the show actually feels.
They've lost nothing.
I always say I'm
the guy with three or four voices.
I probably,
if I probably could come up with more,
but then it still would be
recognizably me.
Dan Harmon Cheats aren't squeaky clean
like he's had his own share of scandals,
but everything that he's been involved in
in the past is very minor in comparison.
In nowhere near Is Spicy is the stuff
that Justin Roiland is accused of.
And he apologized very publicly
and profusely for his past behavior.
Most of his misdeeds were him just being
a low level creep in writers rooms.
If you've seen the text
that Justin Roiland
sent to these underage girls,
they are disgusting.
It's unbelievable
that a human in his position
would think they could get away
with something like this
or just humans in general
would try to do something like that.
I'm almost hoping that some of those
aren't true just because of that bad.
There's all kinds of other accusations
about Justin Roiland flying around.
I don't know how much
of the other stuff is true.
We only have confirmation on the stuff
that's been released publicly.
Personally,
I haven't decided whether or not
to continue making videos for Rick
and Morty episodes in the news release.
They say they're working on season seven.
Before all this, they would have
probably released it during the summer.
I don't know
if they're going to delay it now
because of the big trial
that they're having right now.
I'm just waiting to
they start releasing trailers
to actually make a decision
about what to do
with the future of my Rick
and Morty videos.
I've enjoyed covering the show like
these last several seasons, and it sucks.
One of the creators is actually
so terribly
and it's going to take some time
to process all this.
Like I said, he's
got a trial coming for this in October.
We'll see how that all plays out.
Even if he's exonerated, like I said, he's
not going to come back to the show
or his other projects.
It sounds like he has a lot of mental
health issues to work through.
So hopefully everyone involved with all of
that gets all the help that they need.
That's all I have to say about it now.
I don't really have a bunch of other stuff
to add to it
unless something really
major winds up happening in the case.
Hopefully we don't find out
about even crazier, even worse stuff.
If you have any questions
about what's going
on, what he did,
why this is all happening,
just write them below in the comments
and I'll try to address them all there.
Thank you so much for watching.
And don't worry, I will be back to more
fun stuff in my next video.